being around someone like you and I used
to be the guy who could I don't need to
drink I'd go months and be like oh yeah
I'm gonna drink like you know I love a
drink and and you don't drink and you
haven't drank since you were like in
your 20s I think you know no I haven't
drank since I retired
oh okay science time I felt the effects
of alcohol which i felt quite strongly
was basically the day retired yeah
you're retired which was October 1st
2010 you know of course mean the boys we
went out we had a bunch of drinks I woke
up in the morning cuz I still wake up
early and I woke up in the morning I was
like well yeah that's done because I got
other stuff I got to do now
and basically when I no longer had will
call them friends to drink with yeah and
then I was like yeah well I'm done with
that and I just ever since then
just haven't really you know I've had
and another thing is sometimes people
think I'm like offended if they have
drinks or whatever I'm not you know I
remember actually I went I was on the
first podcast I was on was Tim Ferriss
and we got done with the podcast and he
you know we went out to go grab some
food because I was staying the night at
his house and we went out and we got
some food we got some mistake and he's
like do you mind if I have a glass of
wine with this I was like Katie look
yeah you know a reformed alcoholic just
decided one day you like my dad one day
he was like yeah this gets in the way of
work yeah that's kinda that's kind of my
attitude isn't really yeah yeah and if I
want to drink something that tastes good
then I'll drink chocolate milk I love
the taste of chocolate right I mean that
stuff makes me feel good yeah and I just
yeah and people asked me about a lot of
and I need it's something that I need to
address on the podcast cuz the other
thing is just I might as well double in
just a little bit right at this moment
but when I was a kid I was into hardcore
music yeah I was into and and the type
of music that I listened to was against
drinking and against like it was yeah
yeah we're talking straightedge we're
talking Minor Threat
yeah really yes absolutely and so it was
almost and I was again I was never
really I'm very I'm very I'm not a real
good follower so anytime there's some
kind of a movement going on I'm always
like saying wait why is this movement
going why am I always questioned I don't
just jump in I'm hard to get on board
with something like that so it was
around I wasn't like so there's a
there's a thing with straightedge okay
so this this thing was called
straightedge it started in I'd say Utes
the the epicenter of it was in
Washington DC
the first band really to coin the term
was Minor Threat which is a punk band
Harvard I assumed they were partiers no
not at all by the name No
and so one of the things that one of the
symbols of straightedge was he already
go to a bar when kids used to go to bars
for a show for a for a music show if
they were too young to drink wants to
win the bouncer looked at their ID card
they'd put a big X on their hands and so
the straightedge symbol was they put the
X's on their hands meaning look I don't
drink and it's actually funny cuz I took
my to my kids to see the white buffalo
the other night in San Diego and it was
awesome and but when they came when they
showed their IDs they got the X's on
their hands so what the straightedge
kids would do is they would draw big X's
on their hands meaning hey look I'm not
drinking so there was that an in that of
course morphed into like a gang and
there was you know by the time I was a
you know middle teenager there was
hardcore gangs that would assault people
that drank and would get crazy
while I was together with the Juggalos
yeah so it just so what so when I was a
kid I was okay and I wasn't like a
full-on I wasn't drawing a chi don't
forgot no I never like had X's on
drinking but I but I understood
philosophically what was being said
which was look I want to win right I'm
hardcore I want to be stronger I want to
be aware and I want to be alert and
drinking and doing drugs doesn't give me
any those things so at that that's so
sorry but even at that age
do you understood the fuel that goes
into the Machine affects the performance
yes see I didn't get that as a young
so here I am and and it was you know I
was in discipline and you know I had a
before the seals oh yeah I had a band a
hardcore band the name of my hardcore
band was rage of discipline that was the
name of my hardcore band that was a foul
it's what that's what Bronson's Children
is my first band when I was like 13 was
called Bronson's children but then as I
got older I got more hardcore then it
became a rage of discipline there was
also about no knowledge Brian his
children Bronson Francis Charles he
didn't drink I don't even know Oh name
we do know Charles Bronson was a badass
when I was a kid I thought Charles
Bronson was the man because he needs his
baddest man on the planet yeah he was
you know a tail gunner in a you know
bomber in World War two and he grew up
in the mines yeah when he was a kid when
he's ten years old or 11 years old he
was working in the mines yeah and until
he was old enough the he's to have to
wear a dress cuz he didn't have his
parents didn't have money to buy him
clothes he had to wear one of his
sister's dresses down to the mines
so then he went to World War two and
then he became and you know you he's
just had great movies he always played
this stoic character that was
unemotional and so I was you know hey
when I grew up only be Charles Bronson
of course so then we had a band it was
called Bronson children well as we got
more hardcore eventually that name
morphed into rage of discipline of which
Elgin James was the guitarist who's
another buddy of mine that echoes met
who will come on the podcast at some
point and tell his crazy life story
which I'm a big part of in the beginning
until I turn we got the years of the pre
military Jocko series yeah yeah yeah so
I'll be tuning into that one long story
then I joined the military yeah so when
I joined the military what do I want to
be I want to be I want to be a seal I
want to be a frogman I want to be the
best frogmen I can be I show up at a
SEAL team
guess what frogmen do frogmen drink okay
cool I didn't know that now that I know
that give me a give his shot of
Jagermeister cuz I'm ready to rock and
roll
and that was sort of how you proved
yourself and that's what we did and I
was immature and dumb and and despite
everything I just said about like hey
I'm a little bit I'm hesitant to really
follow well now I'm in the SEAL Teams
this is my dream job and this is what I
want to do
if you don't buy in you're not in yeah
it's like it's not I don't even know if
it's just like that's the way it is yeah
my first drink I was 17 right after I
finished basic training I show up at the
regiment and they're like all right what
are you drinking and I'm like because my
family's full alcoholics on both sides
there's nothing I thought I guessed I'm
like you know grandpa was my other
grandpa was and grandpa's grandpa was
and you know one of my uncle nothing
okay they might hear this but we all
know what you do okay right so not a big
deal but and Dad but dad was one of
those guys he was like well that just
doesn't affect me and me personally like
you as a kid I'm like I don't really see
the interest like what I'm gonna throw
up on myself and whatever whatever and I
was one of those kids that say no to
drugs actually worked on mmm you know
like now I'm older I'm like man I
should've been smoking weed since I was
like 12 and [ __ ] but I still don't but I
did I just like you see the effects on
people like when I was a bouncer I'm
like yeah the guy who smoked weed were
really mellow yeah when the guys did
coke and drank like they were the ones
who the problem but when I get to the
regiment the first night of parade is
done and they're like hey what are you
drinking I'm like well I'm 17 they're
like this is an army mess like it's okay
just don't worry we're all gonna keep it
like it your loves like I'm not trying
to tell the world like hey underage
people drink but hey underage people
drink but it's an environment full of
people that are there to look out for
each other anyway so I had a couple of
drinks and I'm like okay this is the way
it is and same thing yeah work Monday to
Friday you work your ass off you go hard
as you can like you go hard in the paint
right your your tires are stripped at
the end of the day Friday rolls around
okay we don't see it 8:00 a.m. Monday
morning boys
and you know if you're gonna drink don't
drive but if you do drink driver that's
what you got told when you when you're
dismissed for the weekend right yeah and
so basically have a fun blow off the
steam don't hurt anybody and take care
of each other's basically what you're
told
so the SEAL Teams definitely is a
culture it was even more when I first
got in cuz now you're talking about the
old Vietnam guys and it wasn't a war
going on and it was just hey what are
you gonna do if there's no war going on
and you're you're a frogman what are you
gonna do
well we drank and
I'm not I'm gonna look down on I mean we
had a great time it was fun bonded we
you know it was it was fun it was what
you you know was what we did and I'm not
even trying to say anything negative
about it but that's what it was and
unfortunately there's a lot of guys I
shouldn't even say a lot there's a a
decent number of guys that don't do well
with alcohol man and it ruins their
lives that ruins their careers and that
sucks it sucks to see ya I never really
had any issues I drank when I drank and
never interfere with myself in any way
and you know that was that it wasn't a
huge deal and I mean of course what I
mean what I'm talking when I was 19 20
21 22 and we drank a lot we drank a lot
weird how your body like the next
morning probably like it was nothing we
and that's what we did but then like I
said and even now you know and I when I
go out and hang out with some of my old
buddies or actually it's more not what I
just what if I go and hang out with some
my old buddies you know we probably
don't even you know maybe have a beer
but when I go out and see the young guys
the young guys are getting after it I
don't look down on them at all I think
you know getting after it I found I
found when I hung out with my buddies
that are still serving you're not in the
gig anymore you're not doing the job so
you're a little out of shape your your
drills are a little rusty maybe or
whatever I find when I'm around guys my
age that are still operational I can't
keep up with them drinking because it's
part of the training it's part of the
culture I've fallen off and even like
before I was in I didn't really drink
and then when I got out I stopped
drinking as much you know and it's not
like again guys we're not Jocko and I
aren't saying the military we're all
functional alcoholics what we're saying
is it's just what we do yeah and you
know you can remember the job that that
we volunteer to do we weave Ahlan tiered
a-runnin a gunfire yeah you know for our
countries and for fun like let's face it
a lot of us think it's fun I thought it
was the best time of my life
but he's still got to blow off that
steam